a New Hampshire emergency room doctor
with three decades of experience is
sharing what he learned about treating
coronavirus patients with potentially
dangerous cases of pneumonia in a New
York Times op-ed dr. Richard Levitan
described his 10 days volunteering last
month at New York's Bellevue Hospital he
wrote about the simple technology that
he believes could save lives we spoke
with dr. Levitan yesterday who told me
he was very surprised by what he saw in
the ER people were sick for days and
then they only came in with shortness of
breath like the day they presented and
they would arrive with oxygen levels
that basically were incredible to us I
mean almost unimaginable how people
could be awake and alert and have oxygen
levels that are half normal you know
normally we are 94 to a hundred percent
on these devices these pulse oximeters
that measure how much oxygen we have in
our blood and people were showing up
with oxygen levels of 50 percent now
this matches the level of oxygen that
we've measured on the summit of Mount
Everest and it's amazing to me that
patients could be sick for days getting
sicker not realizing it so they had
these very low oxygen levels but they
had no sensation of I can't breathe is
that the plan exactly you were surprised
that they were some of them were still
talking on cell phones why is that
significant you know what is amazing to
me with this disease is people's brains
are working fine their oxygen levels
have gone down to scary low levels but
it has happened slow enough that their
body has accommodated it so they are not
like every other patient we see with
serious lung disease but what I'm saying
is this disease kills by silent hypoxia
and patients should understand that
shortness of breath is a late sign
hypoxia is what exactly is low oxygen
and the reason why it's so important to
get this early warning is because it
could avoid you
being on a ventilator and having to be
intubated right absolutely so you know
we think this pneumonia basically has
two phases this silent hypoxia period
where the oxygen is drifting down what
you feel okay then the second part of
this disease the part of this disease
that kills is when all of a sudden your
lungs get stiff carbon dioxide's finally
starts to build up you begin to feel
short of breath and those patients are
the patients who are presenting with
Kovach pneumonia by then in some cases
it's too late by the time you go to the
hospital and you can't breathe it's a
very serious often dire situation yeah
but let me just reassure people that
what the lessons learned in New York are
are that we don't have to put in
breathing tubes even in most of the
people who show up with advanced COBIT
pneumonia we don't we know they did a
study of 50 patients and what we learned
is that even people who showed up with
significant coke with pneumonia we could
keep off of ventilators three out of
four of them so 75% of patients didn't
need ventilators what they needed oxygen
they needed to do what we call
positioning maneuvers so we put them in
different positions to help open up
areas of their lungs
how do you know dr. Leavitt and when you
should even check your oxygen levels
let's talk about Germany the Germans
have the lowest death rates in Europe
what they do is every patient and who
has COBIT they visit every day and they
check their oxygen and they check their
vital signs and so what I'm saying to
you is if you're having symptoms of
viral illness if you're known to have
Kovac you should be checking your oxygen
if you don't have an oximeter increased
breathing may be a sign of that but also
just feeling worse most people listening
to you will now think I need to get an
oximeter can you explain exactly what
that is and how it works basically you
know you just turn this little button on
and you put it on your finger and within
about 10 seconds or so it displays your
heart rate and your oxygen level I think
that oximeters
in the midst of a respiratory pandemic
and for the next 12 to 24 months that
the public should think of an oximeter
the way they do a thermometer it is a a
tool that they can have at their home
but they can check and that they can
call up their doctor and say hey my
pulse oximeter is reading consistently
at this number is that something I need
to be concerned about I think every day
we're learning something new about this
this this is Kove at 19 and it seems to
be such a moving target always changing
you know what I'm telling you is is
actually hopeful what we are learning
about this disease is it attacks
primarily through one pathway and that's
the lungs we know when it is going to
attack it is going to attack between
five to ten days after infection and we
know we have a way to detect it earlier
and that way is by close monitoring of
pulse oximetry and what I'm saying to
you is that as the public health
messaging shifts we can move the
treatment curve earlier and do much
better for patients oh the thing about
dr. Leavitt and I learned so much
talking to him yesterday because his
whole thing is I don't I'm not trying to
be an alarmist I'm not an alarmist this
is actually offering hope and when he
explained it to me in great detail I see
what he's saying he believes many people
are put on ventilators it may not have
to go on a ventilator if we adjust if
doctors rather had just given them the
oxygen that they needed so I thought
that that was very fascinating and
oximeters by the way are not are not
expensive you can get them at the
drugstore yeah it's very interesting
stuff I mean this is a new virus we're a
complex organism but what this comes
down to according the doctor is
something quite simple we need oxygen we
need air yeah and I love that simple fix
an oximeter I'll be googling that later
today really eye-opening interview thank
you yeah I know you you should have seen
me Tony I got off the interview with him
and went right to the Internet yeah he's
not saying that's always a problem but
that is something that we should start
looking at more carefully